welcome to this video playing gee brain
I have played this Kylie for 30 /
Senate's it's really high rated it
doesn't have any any information and if
you lack or whatever and not a name I
guess nope okay let's see the delayed
exchange in this form I don't think it's
that dangerous I mean certainly playable
but it shouldn't be be terrible for me
very often black takes two moves to get
the bishop to g6 and now I I only had to
spend one move on that it's a very
simple way to play that what is doing
him really this is leading to anything
it's hard to believe but maybe it is
check ok so if it takes here you always
can drop back to 2g three years so
something like we need is not not doing
much
hm
yeah I'm totally unsure here totally not
sure what is right and this this was
what I was aiming for but I'm not really
not sure if it is any good the idea is
that I have play on the light squares
for hoping to claim our sufficient
compensation for the pawn I really don't
know if this is the case but okay I'm
threatening to take okay so if i take
now here what is he doing Bishop deform
well that's not leading to anything
right I can play Queen g6 at least if
I'm not finding anything better okay but
then you can take their take on your
form form maybe something a little
something
okay let's let's do it let's do that
simple simple stuff so look f-4s not a
move I was I was intending this anyway
still trying to play on the light
squares mask a groupie one
rookie one Bishop f3 and he cannot play
five
I mean he can play five I mean I can
take d4f three I JK for this kind of
thing but maybe I'll on e5 I can also
play check on g4 this is a threat anyway
so just just trading down everything now
on with this yeah maybe keep it simple
hmm John
no no problem here really I'm just okay
v5 I've got covered I've got Ruby g5
maybe as a moose but this is not really
doing much this is check can also just
activate the king check yeah maybe I'm I
can do something more ambitious I don't
know what this is completely completely
okay
it is just really really equal there are
your job offer draw him okay Matt that's
really a bit pointless but okay
why doesn't even have an idea in this
position I mean it's it's uh not not
really not clear what what is idea is
with continuing
can even play G for now it's a draw
anyway I can I try to win him I mean he
really made some moves that does not do
not help him at all I mean I can try to
get to go back to his pawns him chan
kingi fire i'm going to run him
so what are you doing here okay so yes
still King g5 is not possible I would
always just I can just walk over here
and maybe maybe I should have plagued
him be fine and b6 it's it's probably
still a draw I mean what he did wasn't
really helping you made all this morning
it's also probably not deadly yeah I can
I cannot play for when you hey I will
try ok I will try freeing the the
Seaport okay and i will walk the sea
porn he will try to to do this
check okay those two pawns are quick
check
yeah I really don't know what what he
did them with with with this play it he
really had absolutely no chance to win
this position I mean I'm not a complete
idiot yeah the only way to try to win us
to lose basically check okay still kind
of tricky here tonight forfeit Sarge I
answer it's amazing ready to know it
just has to take the draw I mean there
is really no way forward whatsoever and
I mean just for draw I can just stay I
can also take here I mean jack like it's
never losing how but the way the way you
plated I mean the only only one with
chant this is clearly black so he let me
take this okay now I goofed around a
little bit and we got to this and it's
this is still a draw I think it should
still be it wrong right it's already
already not easy the comps s Bishop b4
secures the drawer probably a can of one
temple thing this is losing already yeah
simply because the pawns are marching
okay yeah sometimes you just have to
take a draw I mean there was in white
was never ever better in this game may
be around here some what I don't know
that's possible yeah here maybe maybe
here you can do something look t6 some
computer smooth which is kind of add it
is a computer is no game
like this then bishop age six this is
the idea up to six is preparing Bishop
h6 okay they are difficult and TM I'm
already already okay I can't play rook
at seven as well it's just thought that
this should be a kind of a safe option
as yes Chris black as excellent chances
to get get this stuff back but it should
have been a draw it just has to has to
make the draw okay well thanks for
watching